the word science comes from the latin
cientia meaning knowledge
and knowledge comes from know meaning to
recognize to become acquainted with
the science about
knowing
[Music]
the wikipedia defines science like most
other sources a systematic enterprise
that builds and organizes knowledge in
the form of testable explanations and
predictions about the universe
testable explanations
this is odd
it's strange because one prominent
emeritus professor of mathematical
physics tells us otherwise
science doesn't explain
science describes
mathematics is strictly a language
circumscribed to descriptions
mathematics has no power or authority to
explain
the qualitative physical interpretation
offered by a mathematician is
independent
of the quantitative description
synthesized in an equation
but is science about
building and organizing
knowledge
plato defined knowledge as justified
true belief
this definition would stay unchallenged
for the next 2400 years
we have made no substantial improvement
over it
knowledge is ultimately nothing but
belief
when you know
no one can change your mind because you
are absolutely certain of what you know
for sure
if someone shows that you were wrong
does your certified knowledge
retroactively morph into a belief
the problem is that what you know for
sure to be a fact
is subjective and personal
other people might hold different
beliefs
hopefully science is universal and
objective
we show a movie to a crowd and ask each
member of the audience to regurgitate
objectively the mechanism they saw
hopefully all sane people will state
that the box went up because a rope
wound around a pulley pulled it up
and hopefully all same participants
tell you that the glass ended up on the
floor
because a horseshoe was thrown through
the window
likewise if i explain that an astronaut
fell to earth because every atom in his
body is bound to every atom that
comprises our planet
all participants should be able to
explain the same mechanism
in their own words
physical interpretations are about how
the universe works
science is objective
everyone should visualize the same
mechanism
objectivity is not subject to belief
i mean
knowledge
[Music]
you